there was a cat that went viral online I
know this has happened before this one
got a lot of attention it was a very
large cat people dubbed buff cat check
out buff cat you'll see what I'm talking
about
here comes buff cat yeah yeah
and that was that was that was before
dinner well buff cat has become sort of
an internet celebrity apparently that
gave one of the people on our staff an
idea our writers assistant Kathy has a
three pound Chihuahua that she named
Duane the dog Johnson check him out
there's Duane the dog Johnson Kathy
Kathy saw buff cat getting all this
attention so she had her dogs put her
dog in training CrossFit powerlifting
muscle milk all of it the transformation
has been incredible buff cat I think has
real competition now please welcome what
I believe is pound for pound the
strongest pet now in the world Duane the
dog Johnson
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm very happy you can pick them up Andy
I can pick him up yeah and hold a whole
Duane the dog dr. Duane Mason's I mean
we thought that this you know this might
work it might not work the point is it
worked beautifully at rehearsal here's
some proof he's accelerating it's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he couldn't he couldn't avoid the people
you know he is such so it's such a
people please he's such a [ __ ]
he saw the people
you